in 2019 one in 11 people globally were
age 65 and older
by 2050 it'll be one in six
these shifting demographics a
combination of a long-term
increase in life expectancy and falling
birth rates
means the average person is getting
older and while we should celebrate
living longer
we also have to accept that means
working longer too
we really need to think about what this
is going to look like when there's fewer
younger people and more older people and
how
this will work moving forward it could
mean greater economic burden
falling on the shrinking group of
working adults but it could also be an
opportunity
for individuals as well as companies the
multi-generational age diverse workforce
uh benefits in a whole range of ways
those
policies that benefit older workers are
highly likely to
also benefit younger and midlife workers
society is having to adapt to this new
reality the companies that realize that
age is just a number
could reap the biggest rewards
my name is christina matz and i'm an
associate professor at boston college
in the school of social work and i study
the aging workforce
and productive aging
[Music]
so when social security was started back
in 1965 you know the expected life
expectancy
was really around 70 75 and so people
were expected to
you know spend a handful of years in
retirement and so now that we're looking
at
you know 15 20 30 years potentially in
retirement
being able to sustain your income over
the course of that period of time is a
real
issue so does that mean we have to keep
people in work longer or do we need to
rethink the way we work
more broadly it's really important that
we make sure that we
shift away from this focus on
chronological age more to
capabilities and opportunities and
strengths there's still rampant
amounts of ageism that exist in the
workplace
we see it in the rates of re-employment
among
unemployed workers we've actually seen
an increase in age discrimination
throughout the pandemic in recent years
age discrimination has been revealed
beyond the anecdotal and witnessed
across the corporate level
big companies have been accused of
laying off thousands of older employees
to change their image and attract
younger workers
a study for deloitte suggested that if
you're older you're likely to be
considered less capable
less able to adapt or less willing to
pitch in
we found that individuals who are on age
diverse
work teams are more engaged than
those who are age segregated work teams
and so
really having that diversity of opinion
the diversity of skills and talents
the diversity of experience really makes
a huge difference in terms of
engagement other studies have supported
that in terms of
increasing productivity which in turn
increases
the likelihood of the employees staying
with that organization so it
reduces turnover helping older people
stay and work
has wide reaching benefits too according
to a 2015 report
holding on to workers for just three
years beyond normal retirement
could add 55 billion pounds to the
british economy
it could also increase wages and
employment for younger generations
if more older people stay in work
they'll have more money to spend in the
economy
but fixing the age demographic time bomb
as some like to put it
isn't just about delaying retirement for
many older workers
there's a simple reason to stop work our
bodies make it hard to continue
[Music]
at bmw's dingolfing plant in southern
germany
the company had noticed a time bomb of
their own
the average age of the plant workers in
2007 was 39
and was due to rise to 47 by 2017.
former head of the powertrain plant
nicolas bauer was concerned about what
that would mean for productivity
if you bear in mind that older
population
tend to need longer time to cure from a
sickness
have longer absenteeism have maybe
physical abilities which are not as good
as
from young workers what can we do we
have to improve
a the competitiveness of the existing
factory
the planter committed to guaranteeing
employment to its loyal workers
rather than forcing them into early
retirement so it used the situation to
learn about its workforce
and improve conditions we created
a facility within the plant and
installed the age average
that the other plant will have in 10
years meaning
we took elder people brought them to the
line and we took younger people out
line managers work with the employees to
identify what might help them work
better and in more comfort
they identified 70 measures which they
put in place for a small cost
such as changing footwear installing
wooden flooring and adjustable chairs
and adding variety to the stations the
employees worked at throughout the day
it turned out that eight hours on one
workstation is physically very very
demanding we should have a rotation
concept
first something to for for for demanding
for
shoulders and arms then let's say
something for demanding for the legs and
then let's say
something demanding for the brain they
were not
in principle dedicated to improve the
productivity
they were dedicated to improve
ergonomics
but ergonomics measures at economics
also turned out to be very helpful for
productivity
within three months productivity was up
seven percent
the line's absenteeism rate was halved
and the defect rate dropped to zero
all the others which were not dedicated
to that line said
that is the pensioneers line at first
but the pensioners line
proved to be better than all the other
lines within one year
so why do you think the older workers
did better age brings experience
if you are old you have already made
enough forts
which you won't ever repeat 10 years
later i can say
this is more or less basic in every bmw
factory
according to hsbc 15 fewer adults will
join the workforce within the next two
decades
thanks to coronavirus the global baby
drought could be even more pronounced
harnessing the contributions of older
workers could become a serious
competitive advantage
this idea has already birthed a new
career path the return ship
so a return ship is really sort of like
a student internship
except it's tweaked for the mid-career
professional it is a short
term work opportunity where the
company and the individual have the
opportunity to test out the working
relationship
before the employer makes a hiring
decision carol fishman cohen co-founded
ire launch
a company specializing in the career
reentry space
we're working with people who are are
returning to work after career breaks
for a whole range of reasons
and they could be returning in their 40s
50s or 60s
sometimes people are returning to work
after retirement so they're unretiring
because retirement didn't turn out to be
what they thought it was going to be or
maybe
they have financial pressure that they
weren't expecting
what are employers looking for from
relaunches
if you think about the qualities of the
re-launcher population
they're educated they have great work
experience
they have a mature perspective they
have worked before they've worked on
multi-generational teams
they've worked with different
personalities they faced work deadlines
you don't have to teach that
to them our work lives are getting
longer some of us could spend
five or six decades in work so should we
all start thinking
differently about our careers the career
break
can really be a gift and i don't think
people realize that but
once you're on career break it's the
first time many of us
allow ourselves to step back and reflect
on whether we were even on the right
career path to begin with because
if you think about it some of us just
fell into a career without
really knowing that much about it it was
our first job out of school we took
another job in that same area and all of
a sudden
we we had a career uh and others of us
were maybe fulfilling other people's
expectations like maybe
our parents wanted us to go into a
certain field and we were
feeling some pressure and so we did that
and
that's one of the attributes of people
who relaunch their careers
is they have a more mature perspective
they know themselves a lot better
and they have a better sense of where
they can add the most value to an
employer
when you hear progressive workplace
you'd be forgiven for not thinking of
financial services right away
but it's where the return ship actually
started it took off throughout wall
street as the banking industry realized
it was losing successful women
and its senior roles were thinning out
they're intentionally bringing back
people
who are older because they want them to
fill those mid to senior level roles
where
where they haven't had enough women
because of attrition
over time it almost goes counter to what
you might be
thinking about with ageism in the
workforce because
most of the people who get hired through
return to work programs are in their 40s
or
50s or older
while many might dream of retiring early
for most
it's far from reality in the u.s it's
estimated to cost a million dollars to
retire at age 65
yet 21 percent of americans have no
savings
research also shows that people who stop
working and retire
lose social contacts and suffer ill
health employment on the other hand
brings both physical and mental health
benefits and staves off the time we draw
on savings
and pensions we really need to think
about alternative
ways of working more flexible working
arrangements that allow people to
phase out of retirement slowly over a
longer
a period of time considering things like
midlife
sabbaticals considering you know
education
that is more lifelong and extended
across the lifespan
we have to be careful when we talk about
solutions around
working longer to be sure that people
are not pushed out of work when they
really need it
um and pushed out of health insurance
and other benefits that come
with working that older adults often
need
[Music]
you